eu gostaria de compartilhar com vocês
a maneira como eu e meus meus alunos
encontramos de se ensinar geografia e
aprender geografia de um jeito
totalmente diferente mas pra que vocês
entendam um pouco melhor o tamanho das
nossas descobertas
eu preciso compartilhar com vocês
algumas informações sobre a nossa cidade
que nós estudamos durante as minhas
aulas de geografia vinhedo é uma cidade
relativamente jovem com apenas 67 anos
de idade mas com uma ocupação bem mais
antiga datada de meados do século 19 por
torno de 1.840 ainda com o nome de
rocinha
foi lá que imigrantes suíços italianos
escravos ex-escravos decidiram morar
a ocupação dessa área ela se deu ao
mesmo tempo de formas diferentes em
locais diferentes
primeiramente numa área mais alta mais
central onde posteriormente foram foram
se instalar os condomínios de luxo uma
área mais próxima à rodovia a ferrovia
uma área que é muito valorizada em um
segundo momento em áreas mais baixas
mais próximas ao rio capivari em terras
mais baratas e as inundações são terras
onde o esgoto é jogado nessa região de
terras mais baratas que nós temos a
nossa escola na área mais pobre e a
chamada região da capela
esse relevo muito marcante
ele acaba por estigmatizar as pessoas
as pessoas nessa região mais pobre são
marcadas principalmente pela
desigualdade social
e eu pude perceber isso na fala de uma
mãe
no primeiro ano como professor a mãe de
seus cinco filhos
vocês têm que mudar essas notas
vermelhas
vocês dizem que querem que querem mudar
lá pro alto vocês nos disseram que
queriam mudar os condomínios fechados lá
de cima
essa frase a gente percebe o quanto a
cidade é desigual como a concentração de
renda em vinhedo em vinhedo aquele local
que no domingo os e acaba percebendo
muito isso porque você vê nas padarias
ferraris e postes parados
muitos dezenas
infelizmente vinhedo ocupa uma posição
de sétimo lugar no ranking nacional de
diferença de renda dentro da mesma
população
o dinheiro está à frente de grandes
capitais como porto alegre e
florianópolis
é muito importante conhecer dados locais
quando eu tava vindo pra cá eu quis
conhecer um pouco aqui de canoas e eu
fiz uma pesquisa para saber o que eu
encontrar locais que eu gostaria de
visitar o que eu sei a importância de se
entender onde nós estamos
eu descobri que aqui pertinho tem um
sesc 17 com atividades culturais o tempo
todo
também tem o parque getúlio vargas não
muito longe daqui
uma área verde enorme e não muito longe
dali tem o quilombo quilombo urbano
chácara das rosas têm uma história então
de descendentes africanos aqui não é
nós percebemos que os nossos alunos não
conheciam a sua realidade local
eu fiz um trabalho com os alunos para
ver o quanto eles conheciam
é um trabalho muito comum nas aulas de
geografia em que nós pedimos pra que se
desenha o caminho da sua casa até a
escola
isso é muito comum e eu percebi que os
alunos desenhavam sempre as mesmas
coisas os mesmos pontos de referência
não tinha muita variação
os alunos atravessavam todos os dias um
pequeno córrego e quando nós perguntamos
para os alunos se alguém sabia o nome
desse córrego
nenhum dos quase 900 alunos conhecia o
nome do córrego
temos aí que tinha um problema
os alunos não reconhecer um lugar numa
lista onde eles estavam cientes dessa
lacuna
nós decidimos trabalhar isso trabalhar
esse entendimento lugar nos alunos
nós fizemos um pequeno trabalho que
durou muitos meses em que os alunos
fizeram uma pesquisa
eles criaram um censo populacional
nós queremos conhecer quem era essa a
comunidade escolar e um senso seria algo
muito importante pra isso os alunos
elaboraram as questões
a gente também fez uma pesquisa
histórica sobre o bairro
a história de vinhedo não falava muito
de onde eles estavam do bairro da capela
mas existia sim uma história e também
nós trabalhamos com imagens de satélites
para que eles conhecessem os limites das
fronteiras onde eles estavam
até onde iria o bairro deles fizemos um
estudo do meio ao redor da escola
todo esse trabalho de fazer com que o
aluno conheça onde ele está
tem um nome na academia na área
educacional
nós chamamos isso de pedagogia do lugar
e através dessa pedagogia do lugar de se
redescobrir conhecer coisas novas de
onde nós estamos
os alunos fizeram algumas descobertas as
descobertas eles foram foram fantásticas
primeiramente os alunos através de uma
pesquisa na universidade estadual de
campinas unicamp descobriram algo que
não estava nos livros de história sobre
o município
descobrir o que vinhedo não é aquela
cidade de história única tem muitas
cidades aqui no sul
com uma história de imigração de
italianos e europeus vinhedo é assim
quando nós procuramos a história ea
história da cidade
nós vemos que tem a história do italiano
de olho azul tem um memorial do
imigrante tem é uma estátua do imigrante
italiano mas nessa pesquisa nós vimos
que onde eles estavam tinha uma história
negra de ocupação dos negros se
descobriu nessa pesquisa que a região da
capela foi o local de um quilombo também
o quilombo da rocinha com assim era o
antigo nome da cidade de vinhedo
essa história não era contada na
história oficial da cidade porque será
outro ponto importante foi que os alunos
fizeram uma pesquisa sobre o nome das
ruas onde eles viviam
talvez você conheça a história por trás
do nome da avenida
daqui pra frente à avenida victor
barreto os meus alunos não sabiam e
quando eles pesquisaram eles viram o
seguinte
sim muitos nomes das ruas são homenagens
a parentes de vereadores
isso é comum é vereador em homenagem ao
tio dele é falecido
mas eles viram que muitos nomes das ruas
homenageavam pessoas negras que ajudaram
a construir o bairro que trabalharam de
graça na construção da rodovia
anhanguera que corta o bairro
eles viram que havia uma história por
trás dos nomes das ruas
outra descoberta dos alunos
essa foi fantástica porque teria muito
no dia a dia deles
a nossa escola foi construída no lugar
errado as pessoas que pensaram na
construção da escola não era educadores
ou nessa tem não não se atentaram por
alguns fatos tivessem consultado a
população local
eles não teriam colocado a escola e no
trabalho de campo
os alunos puderam perceber algumas
coisas que já vinham acontecendo durante
o ano
quando eles olharam o perfil da escola
eles viram o problema a escola foi
construída praticamente dentro de um
galinheiro
você imagina os problemas de uma escola
estando ao lado de uma grande em
funcionamento o menor dos problemas eram
penas a gente encontrava por todo lado
pena de haver o maior dos problemas
seria talvez alguém ficar doente por uma
bactéria viária
era um sentimento muito ruim você ter
uma escola de uma granja e esse
sentimento piorava
quando os dias quentes o cheiro do
frango eo vento fazia isso para a nossa
escola e os alunos queriam morrer quando
tinha frango de merenda era horrível pra
piorar para você ver como as pessoas não
pensam não é a pessoa que construiu a
escola ali talvez sejam político talvez
seja um engenheiro que não pensou no
local da escola somente usou terreno
vazio se construiu a escola na várzea e
os nossos alunos sabiam desde a 3ª 4ª
série que não se constroem nada na brasa
a vaga é o lugar da mata ciliar ea nossa
escola também foi construída na várzea e
os alunos entenderam o porquê da
infestação de animais infestação de
aranhas infestação de pequenos animais
cobra gambás
eles entenderam então aqui os alunos
perceberam de quem constrói a escola não
é um educador e isso é um problema quem
construiu aquela escola não ouviu a
comunidade que ali era um péssimo lugar
para se colocar uma escola
uma outra descoberta dos alunos a partir
daquele primeiro censo que os alunos
fizeram eles fizeram uma tabulação de
dados
eles analisaram os dados eo incrível foi
que os dados que eles produziram chegava
muito perto ao que é produzido
oficialmente pelo ibge
isso nos deixou muito orgulhosos quando
compararam os dois dados eles viram que
aquilo que o governo faz chegou muito
próximo do que eles produziram isso é
produção de conhecimento dentro da
escola eles fizeram algo que não é muito
comum nas escolas públicas
eles fizeram o que a gente chama de
inversão epistemológica os alunos então
eles não receberam isso dos professores
não foi o professor que transmitiu para
eles essas informações não foram os
livros que transmitirão pra eles eles
analisaram os dados e produziram outra
coisa fantástica que aconteceu foi o
estudo do meio
aqui os alunos e professores
sempre falavam a mesma coisa nós já
conhecemos tudo quando foi proposta em
um passeio um estudo que foi ao redor da
escola
todo mundo chorou ambos falaram isso não
a gente já conhece tudo vai dar certo
mas o resultado foi incrível
primeiro que os professores acabaram se
surpreendendo por muitas coisas que
tinham ali perto
nós tínhamos esse castelinho castelo
medieval que na verdade é um salão de
festa mas que poderia ter sido utilizado
para várias coisas com a contação de
histórias para aulas de história também
tem um bosque próximo que nunca havia
sido usada pela escola um bosque lindo
nesse trabalho o aluno gostou muito do
professor indo até onde ele mora
ele pegando na mão do professor e
mostrando o professor aqui eu só tô pipa
no final de semana aqui a minha mãe faz
compra
aqui é o bar do meu pai
o aluno percebeu que o professor não
estava interessado somente em notas
ali naquele momento o aluno não era só o
número da chamada o aluno tinha uma
história isso foi importante para o
professor conhecer um pouco da
comunidade da vida do aluno porque é
muito comum que o professor entrou com
seu carro no estacionamento de a sua
aula e vai embora
mas isso faz toda a diferença
você conhecer um pouco da vida dos seus
alunos conhecer o bairro em que ele mora
as pessoas que estão ali são essas
pessoas que vão fazer parte das
representações democrática da escola o
conselho escolar da pm é importante que
o professor conheça esse ambiente os
alunos fizeram uma exposição de fotos
como é um bairro pobre era muito comum
você ver no jornal somente fotos de
blitz policial
a apreensão de drogas acidentes e aqui a
gente fez o contrário o aluno mostrou o
olhar dele olhar carinhoso que ele tinha
para o lugar que ele morava
isso foi muito importante e nós fizemos
uma exposição aberta para a comunidade
para que todos vissem o quanto é bonito
lugar que eles moravam
por isso eu convido você aqui agora vai
conhecer o local onde você mora
você sentar e conversar com uma pessoa
desconhecida do seu bairro para ouvir a
história dela para conhecer o que ela
tem para falar ou simplesmente senti e
veja o movimento sintam cheiros veja
dinâmica da onde você mora porque isso é
o que realmente importa
isso é importante trabalho essa
pedagogia do lugar onde você está
as pessoas elas elas vêm os lugares de
diferentes maneiras
então não deixe que um guia turístico
fale como é onde você vive um corretor
de imóveis diga como é onde você vive
mas você lá conheça você todos os
meandros da onde você mora trabalha essa
pedagogia do lugar
obrigado